et à la dalle alors c'est incroyable les
bonbons leçon ranger les jouets sont à
leur place
c'est la première fois que tout est en
ordre
gallant vais pouvoir aller jouer avec
casimir est france par kasimi way à quoi
tu joues vois rien je m'embête tard ce
bouton
thank you je voudrais savons qu'une bête
oui c'est comme ça au nom badges et
aujourd'hui je n'ai aucune idée alors
sont agaçants quand même pour la
première fois que j'ai réussi à faire
mon travail
personne n'a envie de jouer avec moi
j'ai une idée
les enfants vous voulez ou va vous
voulez faire un pique nique à décider ce
qu'il faut apporter ça c'est une bonne
idée un audit casimir et julie je peux y
participer au pique nique
oui mais alors vous montrer un peu plus
d'enthousiasmé ouais ouais ouais ouais
d'accord avc promis alors on va faire la
liste des objets emportés attend
d'accord je prends un crayon et du
papier et je vais les habitants le
casting pour un pique nique
vous savez on va chercher alors alors
qu'est ce qu'il faut c'est très très
bonne réponse dit del rey albane du
maire à moi je n'irai j'ai pas le temps
d'écrire lier un bouclier pourquoi les
gt éclaboussures de confiture très belle
gaza
borloo n'est pas c'est pas bête bono
marque d acier dans les fougères
voilà des papiers un tuyau d'arrosage
pour se servir à boire encore une idée
géniale de gaz hier à vos bons bon bah
je crois qu'on a eu la tâche à des
bonbons à temps des travaux
on va emporter ce câblage après on fait
la liste après alors assiettes verres qu
un serviette bon ben ça va très bien
voilà et maintenant que va t'on danger
oui bon d'accord moi je vais t'aider à
fait un peu plus puisque tu as passé ta
liste tu mangeras rien tu sais même pas
ce qu'on va porter après ils sont 606 on
s'attend pas tcd jaffray saucisson sec
pour la rue mais on va faire des
sandwichs avec tout ça alors du pain
donc avec du pain comme gâteau je ne
sais pas car c'est beau très bien quoi
alors du jus d'orange il aura alors de
nos remarques et puis
2 sur wii je pense à l'aps et rougerie
et que quand on aura mangé tout ça je
crois une hormone ah bon le ventre bien
rempli
bon petit souviennent du lait de laurent
jats d'un gâteau d1 et quoi d'autre on
avait là je viens de me souvenir de tout
mais t'en fais pas ton fait pas casimir
j'ai tout noté sur ma liste bompard
féministe ça ira
son désir l'a qualifié de quasi vie
revienne mais il a oublié sa liste enfin
heureusement que j'ai tout l'été et je
crois qu'il faut mieux que jai modem a
tout de suite les enfants
je vais faire les commissions voilà j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut aller magnifique sur
le monde s'installe
chacun pense qu'il faut réserver
remettez la table oulala le gâteau
bref les gobelets des gâteaux et caramel
les petites assiettes ce qu'il faut dit
dans france soir
oui je suis inquiète pour casimir ya
longtemps qu il devrait être là bas
tient justement le voilà qui arrive
j'étais parti en oubliant la liste on
s'en est aperçu tu sais françois l'avait
prise tout ce qu'il faut mais moi aussi
j'ai rapporté à manger alors qu'on ne
l'avait pas la liste j'ai pris ce qu'il
y avait de meilleur et qui sont gardés à
porter l'âge et des ailerons de requins
sauce moutarde leur demander quelque
chose que natasha bien aimée des
escargots à la confiture de groseilles
c'est très bien des papillons antibes de
mieux en mieux le futur de s'offrir les
enfants ecoutez-la de tortue au piment
écoute casimir arrête tu va nous couper
l'appétit
[Musique]